so would you be up for us maybe take in
a couple absolutely yes well where is
Ramsey so Jessica I heard that you went
in the car accident and you quoted my
stutter started soon after and a doctor
said it was from the head injury my mom
said that when I started it looked like
my brain and I were trying to say 10
things at once my voice just wouldn't
work so from this trauma why did you go
into singing that actually singing was
the best way for me to communicate I've
heard about that so I got into singing
and that was literally the way that I
could express myself and how everything
like was clear oh yeah I don't know what
caused the stuttering I mean it could it
could have been from the car accident
something you know like very traumatic
other traumatic things that I went
through as a child but and I also have a
million thoughts in my head at all times
me too like somehow trying to balance
that I might as well just sing through
it I love that I love that great
question so next question though it's
from Ashley right where's Ashley hi
Ashley hi Kelly hi Jessica I guess I
could talk about being sober and you're
actually just speaking about now what
brought you to the point where you felt
like you had to get sober well being a
mother like I mean my kids at the time
were five and four so I I grew up with
no alcohol in the house and I was but I
mean I was at a place where I was
literally like spiraling with the
alcohol like and but I and I was missing
out moments of like missing out on
moments with my children and then they
were seeing me and they were very
confused and I I just wanted to be
present and have and have clarity and be
a good role model for my children
because I always wanted to be a good
role model for the world so why in the
world would I like be stuck in the cycle
of having to like wake up and have a
drink before going to one of their
school assemblies it got to the point
where all of my life had like escalated
and I I couldn't suppress it and alcohol
it wasn't it wasn't working it was
making
just completely check out subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going